amber is in Ohio hi amber welcome to the
Dave Ramsey chef hi Dave thanks for
taking back home sure what's up so I am
trying to figure out a way that I can
get out of debt I have about I'm like
over thirty thousand in debt I make
about thirty four thousand a little over
thirty four thousand a year I had two
boys and a single about married and I
really want to do this
it'd be a great achievement working
family has ever been I bet he's died in
debt still have debt that is the thirty
thousand so I have thirty thousand
fourteen Wow yes and then I have about a
little over 13 thousand good student
loans is that about I'm gonna say the
rest of their like three thousand
evidence credit cards okay all right how
much is your car note it's 350 oh okay
so you got a high interest rate to go
with it what do you do for a living yeah
I work at a classes at progressive old
are you 27
did you finish school when you got
student loans I did not I did how to
balance yeah well that's fair how far
how far along did you get I got about a
year in and all this was attempting
trying to go back and keep trying to go
back and it just would work for me I
would either in the Polish or a place to
go do you have family in the area
yeah I do I do have vegetarian repent
oh that's good okay all right you are
why we exist here right okay you have a
tough tough situation and you have a
tough three to five years in front of
you but we're going to walk with you and
help you do this okay okay all right so
there's several things going on one is
you got your hands full you got two
little boys as a single mom and you're
working your butt off and you're tired
and you're trying to think about how I
can still have a future in the middle of
all that you don't have a lot of margin
in your time and you don't have a lot of
margin in your money am i right that's
correct
okay so but basically what we've got to
do in order to attack this is we've got
to get your income up and your outgo
down no kidding right you knew that
no kidding Dave well that's why I get
the big bucks okay so but we got you
know thirty four thousand you're making
it okay but it's gonna be very difficult
to knock this debt out and for that
matter to prosper and for that matter to
do well so we need a game plan that says
the 37 year old amber is making 80
thousand and what are our steps to get
there okay and I don't care what it is
that's legal and moral and that you're
proud of but we're gonna move you along
that way and that's probably going to
involve some community college classes
or something like that along the way
you're gonna have some expense it's
definitely going to involve some extra
work some part-time work that's why I
asked about family in the area but it's
not gonna be that this is a way of life
it's what I have to do to get where I
need to go does that make sense all
right
because you if you keep doing what
you've been doing you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting agreed
agreed so let's get your income up I
want to start talking about that car
yeah and what we can do to get rid of
that thing and get you a cheap car what
kind of car is it amber
so it's a 2013 Ford Fusion Hybrid and
you're still buying 14 did you just buy
that about a couple years ago so let's
really quickly here so what happened was
it's about two or three years ago I got
a letter in my mailbox from a creditor
and I found out that my mom had taken
out a five thousand dollar loss for
furniture her name when I was still high
school and I started working I was
making money and they were going to
start garnishing so I start talking to
other people my family is my auntie
meals like okay you could do right now I
was filed for bankruptcy I had never
even had a credit card at that point and
I filed for bankruptcy and I got rid of
that but then my car broke down I have
used off 24 you know and say this is
this is the cycle this is a cycle that's
going to keep happening until you break
the cycle with getting the income down
and the outgo are the in come up and the
out go down and so we've got to move you
out of that car into something cheap I
don't know how we're gonna do it we're
gonna work with you though and we've got
to get you where you get your income up
so I'm gonna stack you up with materials
and with support to help you get all
this done but then you're gonna have to
go do it cuz it's gonna be hard it's
gonna be really hard okay and and here's
the thing amber with the stuff that
we're gonna stack you up with before you
even dive into it here's what I want you
to do attend today and tomorrow before
you get this stuff I want you to write
down what's your vision for your life
why and don't answer the question like
what I just want to get out of debt well
why do you want to get out of debt then
when you get that answer go even deeper
well why do you want that because like
Dave said these next two to three up to
10 years are gonna be difficult for you
it's gonna require some hard work some
require you telling your friends no it's
gonna require you telling you
how many years ago were you living in
your car that was when I was 19 so 16
years ago 16 years ago and you've been
here five years you know five so it took
I mean less a little less than a decade
and your entire life was transformed
from the back of your car absolutely
okay so that's an important fact again
so we're telling you the truth this is
not going to be an easy quick fix but
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
sign you up for a year in Financial
Peace University
Madison is also going to connect you
with one of the coaches that has been
trained by us and we're going to pay for
it
no cost to you no cost to you on
Financial Peace University I want you to
go through that class I want you to get
in those groups I want you to get on
that budget I want you to sit down with
that coach and the coach can help work
you out of this car into a cheaper car
get your credit cards cut up and start
talking to you about an extra job the
other thing we're gonna send you
completely free is all of Ken Coleman's
materials die solid yeah his book
proximity principle you become who you
hang around with and your mom what she
did there was pure evil pure I was wrong
and I know she's your mom but that's
wrong to do that to your kid and
basically puts you in bankruptcy you
weren't bankrupt if you'd had some
knowledge you could have gotten out of
it but she might have been bankrupt yeah
but you know the you got you got the
people around you aren't giving you good
information and that's some of those
that are well intended some of them
aren't but that's the proximity
principle we become who we hang around
with and so get a hold of that book read
that book and get on his website and
start learning about how to dress up
your resume and start thinking about
what you can do to create extra income
go ahead and throw her in a business
boutique book from Christie right - she
may want to start a side hustle yeah
side hustle with two little boys might
be a better way than a side job yes if
somebody's there to watch the kids some
side jobs but you've got some extra
income that's we created on the
short-term and then a better career
track on the long term for extra income
and that begins to change
your family tree that and with the idea
that you stopped with some of the stupid
though debt and the credit cards and the
student loans little classes that
weren't finished and all that kind of
stuff killing you just killing you these
fits and starts and panicked purchases
are taking you apart so you're you're a
sharp young lady and you got a lot on
your plate we love you and we want to
help you and you hang on Madison will
pick up and we're going to walk with you
through every bit of this